my goofy hick dancing oh brother where
art thou makes me laugh every time i see
it because
there was a choreographer there who'd
come up and said i'd like to talk to you
about a dance and i was like
i kind of have my own dance i want to do
and he's like no no i go
oh yeah
[Applause]
and when i did it i just remember
hearing the cone brothers
they laugh too loudly off camera all the
time you know and
just hearing them both going laughing
will always be a great sense of joy for
me
[Music]
out of sight i remember
reading the screenplay i just i'd done
batman and robin
and i knew that i needed to find a
better script
to work on for the next film so i waited
about a year
and this movie came around and there was
another there was a director attached to
it
and the studio came to me to play the
part
and when they came to me the director
quit because he said i wasn't a movie
star
which is fair enough he's probably right
and so we had to go look for a director
and so we had a meeting with danny
devito who was the producer then with
stacy cher and michael schamberg
and we went through a list of directors
and steven soderbergh's name
came up and he was having a rather
unsuccessful run he had just done a
movie called the underneath
and it was a moment in time where both
stephen and i
needed a success quite honestly we
needed a hit
other site never was a hit actually it
was critically
well liked but it wasn't a hit and so it
was it was a really good time for both
of us to come together and meet and
you know i got to play this really fun
character who
just really loves robin banks she's got
one flaw man
you see the man talking to your bank
manager has his case open
oh that's mr gwyndon one of our
assistant managers our manager is mr
schoen but
he's not in today but you see the man
with the briefcase
yes that's my partner he has a gun in
there
if you don't do exactly what i tell you
or if you give me any kind of a problem
at all i'm going to look over at my
partner and he's going to shoot
your mr glendon between the eyes
you know but he also falls in love with
the cop which is usually a a problem
can buy a drink
yeah i'd love one
every actress in town read for that part
and part of it was that she had to be
sexy but you also had to believe that
she could shoot you
and kill you and jennifer had all of
that
you know you believe every minute when
she picked up a gun she might pull the
trigger and blow your head off
and she was really good she was
wonderful in the film and um
it's funny because uh you know she's had
an
amazing career and gone on to do so many
things and sort of be an all-around
entertainer
but i think if you look back that's a
performance that really
stands out for her and uh that extra
pillow you want to get that for you but
that's going to be like
five c's fine hey
sign says shut the [ __ ] up or can't you
fellas read
you talking to man you got a problem
over there
that's the first time i got to work with
don cheadle
and uh we've done i don't know seven or
eight things together since then and are
very close friends
don makes every film better that's the
truth
what's going on here uh nothing you know
just reading this fundamentalist
we just got all excited and everything
and there were so many wonderful
performances by so many wonderful actors
and it's a movie that really holds up
scott frank wrote the screenplay and in
general you couldn't go wrong with it
because
there were such great other supporting
roles
with wonderful actors in them but there
were such great parts that you
you kind of wanted to go off and see
what white boy bob's life was like or
you wanted to go off and see what dennis
farina's life was like you know
every character had such a lively
interesting world isaiah washington with
his
with his crazy hair and you know and
each of the characters i mean
you know viola davis has a small part
and i've done i don't know how many
projects with her as well tiny part in
it but she just knocks it out of the
park
they're just such really flushed out
gray characters which you don't get to
see all that often
elmore leonard movies in general weren't
very good um
no fault of anybody the the screenplays
they would try
you know when you adapt a movie from a
book you try to adapt the plot
which is what you try to do because and
then you try to weave in your characters
elmore leonard movies diamond heist 52
pickup whatever the movies are
the characters are the secret and scott
frank first
adapted get shorty that was the first
elmore leonard film that really worked
it worked really well
and that's because scott understood just
focus on the characters the the the
heist isn't that interesting
and this one was a diamond heist and
it's not that interesting a heist you
know the
diamonds are in the fish tank big deal
you know but what was
spectacular were all of the characters
in it you know ving rhames character
originally was called red and he was a
big redheaded
white guy and i remember soderberg and i
were talking were like
all the bad guys are black and all the
good guys are white
and uh we thought ving should play my
best friend and he and i had been
working on
er together and uh so that made it fun
you know
honestly it was just a really wonderful
time and you're right it was fun to be
in miami at that point it was
it's a good time to be there
oh brother where are they i was on the
set of three kings
in arizona i sat down with them they had
the script
they you know that was the year that
they had fargo out you know
and they'd never done a bad film and
they said we have a movie would you like
to be in it and i said yeah
and joel goes do you want to read it and
i go yeah i'll read it but yes i'm going
to do it
and then i took the script back to the
hotel room
in arizona and i read it and i couldn't
believe my luck i couldn't believe that
that i was going to play this guy
everett
join you two ignorant fools and
ridiculous superstition thank you anyway
and i like the smell of my hair
treatment the pleasing odor is half the
point
baptism you two are just dumber than a
bag of hammers
well i guess you just might cross the
bear over everything these are kind of
big breaks in your life to work with
directors who you just adore
and to be able to do a part that's
really fun and funny
and they said you know we wanted to be a
hick and i was like well i'm from
kentucky
and he's they said okay well can you
pick it up a little bit and i was like
sure
and my uncle jack who was living in
harrisburg kentucky at the time
i sent him a tape recorder and i said
read all my lines
out of the script into this tape
recorder i get the tape back and i
listen i turn it on it goes
georgia i don't think folks around here
talk quite like us here but we'll give
her a go
and i was like got exactly what i wanted
how you doing son
name's everett these two soggy sons of
[ __ ] are
pete and delmer keep your fingers away
from pete's mouth he ain't had nothing
to eat for 13 years
set prison food gopher and a little
greasy horse the coen brothers the way
they write they don't change a word they
don't edit anything you know they
you when you get the script the script
you get is the script you shoot all the
way through it's very rare it's like
that
and so you i learned every line like
shakespeare because you can't really
improvise in the middle of a a of a coen
brother's run they write such specific
things
and so i you know i'm doing all the
scenes and every time i came to a scene
you know be like
you know delmar where the where the heck
turner yeah
you know where is you where you know
where in the heck are you
and stuff and joel came up to me and he
said why is it that you say
every line exactly like we wrote it
except you never say hell
and you never say damn i was like you're
kidding
and you go no and because i'd thrown the
script away i was just listening to the
tape
and what i realized my uncle jack who's
a baptist when he said i don't think
folks talk like this
he meant about cussing so he completely
took out all the cuss words and said
heck and dern
you know and so i was doing it heck what
the darn so my uncle jack rewrote uh the
coen brothers he's the only one to ever
do it
it's my uncle jack
well no one would have ever picked that
it would have won
album of the year over u2 no one have
ever picked that
tim got paid more than any of us because
he was singing on the album
you know that opening sequence with the
guys with the pickaxe
was an actual old i think wire recording
that t-bone brunette found
of an actual chain gang singing
and when you can't find the writer of a
song
then it goes to the singer the royalties
go to the singer
so they found the guy one of the guys
who was singing
who'd been on a chain gang in like the
60s or 70s
and they had they knocked on his door
and were like here's a check for seven
hundred thousand dollars for a song and
you're saying while you're on a chain
gang in 1970 you know
pretty great story no idea that the
album would take off
like that and uh you know we all loved
the music but we never thought that
would that would be the case i mean
it was the number one soundtrack for
almost
two years i mean it's just crazy you
know how
how popular that's the the soundtrack
was the ocean's trilogy
there's a fun thing about that gang is
there's there was
literally no ego involved in it and
there's a funny thing you see and you
can see it in those the
the way that the scenes play there was
no actor in those scenes trying
to steal scenes they're all kind of
actively trying to hand it to the other
guy you know
you you you've got the funny better you
do this and so there's such generosity
of spirit
and throwing things away in in such a
way that
it's so easy going and so fun i remember
julia i didn't know i'd never met her
and
she was making 20 million dollars a film
and we just
talked brad into doing it and matt into
doing it
and we wanted julia to do it so i put
the 20 bill on the script and i sent it
to her and i said i hear you get 20 a
picture now
you're a thief and a liar i only lied
about being a thief
i don't do that anymore steal lie
i'm with someone now who doesn't have to
make that kind of distinction no he's
very clear on both
you know what your problem is i only
have one you've met too many people like
you
i'm with terry now does he make you
laugh
he doesn't make me cry she was
spectacular to work with and as a
dear friend and those guys you know i've
done a lot of movies with brad and matt
over the years because of that but that
was my first meeting of them
and the very first day we got together
it felt like
you know it just felt easy and fun and
we were all kind of
living in las vegas and you know
i'm the cooler no one lets me near the
gambling table ever
i mean literally if you've got 20
showing the dealer will
pull a 21. i'm just that guy if i'm
sitting there
matt would always go just get out get
away go away he'd stand up and yell
we need a high paying job well now we're
too hot to work anywhere in this country
so we go abroad how about we go on the
five o'clock
good where are we going amsterdam
amsterdam it is clock's running guys
let's go all right
then we went to europe and did the 12
and
we shot some of it in lake como which
was my hometown and
brad sent out a memo
to all the people in the town my town
i'd lived there for years
but he had it posted on like telephone
polls and said you know
the movie is coming to town and please
only address
mr uh uh george clooney is mr clooney or
in his in his character name of danny
ocean and don't look him right in the
eyes
so the papers was like ill divo george
clooney is el divo
well that was a horrible story which i
later got him back for
13 we were back in la and shooting with
the al pacino which was a blast
he came in and just immediately got into
the swing of it like
let's have some fun one reason not to
bounce your ass out of my place you know
the reasons you already decided before
you walked over here
they were all booked here you took them
what'd you do bribe them
the only person had a hard time with
soderberg who had to put it all together
but
wrangled the cats you know there's some
things that are just
laughable we would get in laughing fits
on the dumbest
things like i remember you know because
i'd always have to do the setup like i
had all the dialogue where i'd have to
go
okay here's what we're gonna do you're
gonna do this and we have those like
all-night shoots where it's like you
know 12 hours
and i remember i'd gotten through it on
their coverage i said let's do all
everybody else's coverage first this is
like 10 pages of dialogue
let's get through all and shoot them
first of all really have it down so when
you turn around on me
great so he and i would nail that nailed
it nailed it nailed and nailed it
and then camera turned around at me and
i start and i go and then you're gonna
go
uh you're gonna go into the chamber and
then up the chute
and then don just goes or is it
up the chamber and into the chute and
everybody went
and i went oh and then from that moment
on i couldn't get
one line right i mean it was all
literally we did it in like one line at
a time i was completely
shot to hell and don's like i'm sorry
man
we would do hysterical like idiotic
things like
there was a house when we were we were
all staying at my house in like como and
there was a house across the lake it was
empty and we
made up a story there was an italian
book about it we'd made up a story about
how
haunted it was and my buddy giovanni was
italian
he's pretending to read this story where
this guy would kill people and
you know throw them into the lake and
talk to everybody into like
how you know dangerous this house was so
three in the morning
we get a ladder and we put on this
pontoon boat and
matt and don and brad and i took the
boat across the water
took the ladder up and climbed in the
house the first thing we saw was like a
statue of a snake eating a woman's head
or something like oh so we came down to
the conclusion was
we give ten thousand dollars to any guy
that could spend the night in the
haunted house with just a candle and a
bottle
you gotta you got a candle you got six
matches and a bottle of wine
and we left um i guess we left cheadle
and pit there
and matt and i came out we're sitting in
the boat in the middle lake and we have
to see the candle go by every window
it goes by like two or three windows and
then we get a call and they're like [ __ ]
that get us out of this house
we came back and pulled them out so
there's a lot of idiocy that went on
you know along the way but we had a
really wonderful time
and they're you know they're all still
very dear friends so
good night and good luck i've been very
vocal about
my opposition to the iraq war in 2003
and people like bill o'reilly was doing
shows on why my career was over because
i was
unpatriotic american and they were
organizing boycotts of films i was in
and things like that
and so i wrote goodnight good luck as a
in protest in the idea of
of how you know i felt like the fourth
estate
the news organizations had dropped the
ball and asking the tough questions
and what happens if the other three
estates fail
how important it is that the fourth
estate stands up and i look back and i
remembered the murrow
and mccarthy story i remember the army
mccarthy hearings and so i started
writing about that
so we raised you know like 6 million
bucks which is pretty low budget for
that we shot it in 24 days
on one sound stage and from the moment
we started that
everybody got it you know we would give
all these
the the the guys who played murrow's
boys
a copy of a newspaper we'd say okay
here's a
this is you know november 5th 1954
new york post and they would sit at the
typewriter they'd all get their
different
newspapers they said a typewriter and
they'd pull stories
from it and then we'd have two cameras
hidden inside the
screening room and i was playing fred
friendly who was the producer
and i would go okay what's your lead and
each of them because they'd all
pulled all of the pages they owned the
story and they would go
well nixon got kicked out of going to
duke university because you know
and it really gave it this live cinema
verite
feeling and i knew all along that i
wanted to use
diane reeves singing as a chorus like a
greek chorus to it that just was
constantly had this
this beat going through it that was uh
that was our soundtrack
and with the other than that no score
get the shot he wants to do the story
joe
remember delbert clark no longer with us
new york time yeah our friend at the
time yeah
this is yesterday morning they're saying
it's uh how old is he
53 illness uh sudden illness home of a
friend
no it's not novid piece natalie sent
some flowers over there from the cvs
a couple things case before the supreme
court involving the constitutionality of
a section of the internal security act
um provides for the deportation of any
alien if he becomes a communist after
entering this country
i screamed for mike nichols and he loved
it and then i
and i never screened it for anyone else
and we went to the venice film festival
and at the end we got this you know five
or six or seven minute standing ovation
and we didn't know at the time whether
anyone would get it
you know we had no idea we thought it
was just a little protest
film because if they are right and this
instrument is good for nothing but to
entertain
amuse and insulate then the tube is
flickering now and we will soon see that
the whole struggle
is lost this instrument can teach
it can illuminate and yes it can even
inspire
but it can do so only to the extent that
humans are determined to use it towards
those ends
otherwise it is merely wires and lights
in a box
good night and good luck i have a lot of
journalism teachers from colleges
who uh use that film as a as a teaching
tool which i'm very proud of
it's important to watch that film now
and hear what murrow talks about
just the idea of saying we will not be
driven into an
age of unreason we are not you know born
of fearful men
and men who feared to write or speak
against things that were for the moment
unpopular
it's important to remember that those
those words
and every bit of it still plays
unfortunately
it was the beginning of a commentary in
news
how important that was and it's
important to remember how important that
was it did
help bring down mccarthy and the
craziness of what mccarthyism was and it
was crazy
there's revisionist history now people
like to change the rules but
it was crazy hold up a blank piece of
paper and say i got a list of names
it was ruining people's lives but it
also opens the door
for the you know sean hannity's of the
world
it also opens the door for commentary by
much less responsible people tucker
carlson's of the world
who can just spew anything and say
so um as as important as it was
you always wish they were walter
cronkite or edward romero and
hope that they're not um laura ingram
and bill o'reilly when you open that box
that's what you get sometimes
michael clayton you know we were
shooting in new york
and it's kind of winter and nasty
everything about it felt a little
heavier while we were there
but i have to say if you know
tom or if you know tilde matilda is the
funniest of them all because she always
plays sort of these cold
[ __ ] uptight you know
characters and she's got the greatest
laugh she's one of the funniest most
engaging
fun human beings i've ever met in my
life truly
like and enjoys life like a tax life in
a way that is so
fun and she was spectacular in it 10
million dollars
your account the moment this meeting is
karen everyone's waiting i'm coming don
you have a deal you're so
what you're f what do you mean
take a wild guess is there a problem i
don't understand here let me get a
picture while i'm at it
you don't want the money no you keep the
money you're going to need it i get to
win in that one and
usually he doesn't you know that's the
thing about
if you look at my career i played an
awful lot of crooks
or people who've done some sort of you
know crooked things in life
this guy is a crook who who you know
is his own worst enemy and doesn't win
those arguments
you know i go in and talk with the
lawyers and they're like you know look
here just take this payment and shut up
and every single
argument i get into i lose you know and
so at the end
with tilda i got the goods on her and
she's finally
caught in the way that we hope we get to
catch
these you know the corporate malfeasance
that we're talking about before the way
we want to catch them
so for us it's that great relief of we
caught the big company doing the shitty
thing
it's not that it's going to cost them
money it's not that they're going to get
fined
they're going to go to jail and that's
what we want you want to see these
people handcuffed and walked out
and it's a really good movie because it
gives you all of the
you know it has a payoff at the end all
right here we go that guy right there
stop
him grab that guy
what are you doing with detectives with
the nypd i'll tell you
an interesting thing people don't know
it was based on
an investigation on the ford pinto and
it kept if you hit it from behind it
would blow up
this car that was made and the the idea
was that
ford eventually had to recall it but
there was a scandal about it which was
that
there was an internal document from ford
at the time
that said look it's going to cost us
a billion dollars to recall all these
ford pintos
11 people a year die from getting hit
from behind class action suits would
cost us 200 million
our thought is it's cheaper to absorb
the
11 deaths and the 200 million class
action suit
than to recall all the cars that piece
of paper got into the hands of a judge
and he said okay now you're all dead
and everybody was fired and a huge huge
class-action suit
he couldn't do that story necessarily
tony didn't want to do that story but he
based
michael clayton on that so it was always
based on the idea of this corporate
malfeasance
the idea that um that everything
and all the machinery the lawyers and
all of these pieces that have to come
into play
to make these things work to make them
get away with these kind of things
so it was based on real deep important
subject matters but it was still a you
know it was a fiction as a work of
fiction
so that you could play with the story a
little bit more and without
worrying about lawsuits and that kind of
thing
we talked for a while about how we
wanted to end the film
knowing that the end of the film really
was me walking away
but we had to end it and it needed to
land
we sort of came up with the end of the
graduate and how when they get in the
back of the bus at the end of the
graduate they just sit there for a long
time and
first it's they live happily ever after
and then you sit with them for a while
and it's like
what have we done and holy [ __ ] so
tony goes okay well let's just put you
in the back of the car and we'll just
leave the camera
again if that was a shot you did the
beginning of the movie would be the most
boring shot in the history of film but
it's a shot where everyone watching it
sort of relives
their version of the movie through me
through what i'm
thinking so they're playing it through
and it's their version of it that goes
through
but we didn't have the permits to shoot
in new york city in the middle of the
afternoon
so we're just stealing the location so
we get in the car
and the car is covered with lights all
around it and a camera
two cameras mounted there i think and
we're going in
middle of high traffic through like
fifth avenue right just the middle of
new york
and so everyone was like god what were
you thinking when you were going through
that what was going through your mind
you know
what was you know how are you you know
because
we see we learned so much about the
character from
all i was trying to do was not laugh
because
every time like we'd stop at the light
people pull up like they'd see
you know they're looking in because
there's all these lights on this camera
they go that's just cluely
hey george clooney what are you doing
man
hey and i'm just looking straight ahead
you know looking like right towards the
camera
and all i'm trying to do is not crack up
for like three and a half minutes
because everywhere you go
hey joy look at that george look at me
yeah
you know and uh it still makes me laugh
this day because when i watch the film
all i can see
is me trying not to laugh and everybody
else sees something completely different
you know
the descendants the sentence was
interesting because it was the first
film i'd ever played where i was really
the wuss you know my wife was cheating
on me
you know like there's a scene where i
run in flip-flops that i specifically
tried to run like a dork and
it was one where you you know i'm not
athletic i'm not
in control even if i'm not in control
you know you don't get to tell anybody
really off
my seven-year-old daughter is smarter
than i am
and you know more it has better sense
than i do
so i never played a character that was
that lost before and
and that betrayed before your mother
wanted it this way she has this
she has this will see that says that
that we have to do it this way
we both do
all the actors and there were some
really wonderful actors there to work
with
but shailene you know she was a
professional
but she was more than a professional
when she walked onto that set
i think one of the first scenes we shot
i think we're letting her go because
when i tell her
her mom's not going to make it and she
dives underwater
she cries underwater and i've never seen
anything like in my life
and i said to her then i go look i don't
know what's going to happen with this
film but you
don't worry about your career it's funny
over the life of
our lives now you know we write each
other and
i really do consider her like my eldest
daughter you know
she is a dear someone i dearly love
i was on my way to swim in the black
point pool with brandy
and suddenly i see mom and some
douchebag walking into a house
his house i guess just some guy it could
be anybody alexander payne i think is a
brilliant brilliant director and
his understanding of what i needed to be
and it was you know fascinating because
i
i would my my persona is
to push against being the guy that gets
a pie in the face
i always figure i'd like to do any part
but i don't want to be the guy that gets
a
you know somebody throws a pie in your
face and then everybody laughs at you
and the only way that the film works is
if for the first
two-thirds of the film i'm the guy that
gets the pie in his face and
you have to let it happen you just have
to there's no other options
and so it was not a comfortable acting
job for me
in that way because you know everything
is like everybody
you know everybody who comes in the room
is smarter than me and everybody's
got their act together better than i do
so it was a trickier one
but i also knew that i was in such good
hands
alexander hadn't had a movie not be
successful
you know not be critically successful
and the script was terrific
i knew my part was great by the end i
knew the scene where he says
goodbye to his wife was
his sort of moment of strength and his
moment you know when
i knew that the story had a circle to it
and that circle would be
eventually joined and i knew that the
family being back together was gonna
work
again another sort of tableau shot with
everybody just sitting there
uh you know watching television together
but i felt like
in the hands of alexander i didn't i
wasn't worried about it at all
midnight sky i knew
that ultimately it was a story about
redemption
and it was a story about it was a much
smaller story
i have to warn them about the conditions
on earth
you know i wanted it to be like a silent
movie in some of it i wanted it to be
a meditation in a way of loss
we weren't in the middle of a pandemic
when it happened but there were still
all these other elements
you know these elements of how much
hate and anger were sort of all of us
experiencing at this moment in our
history all over the world you know go
to
bolsonaro in brazil or orban and hungary
or
look around lots of anger and hate
and that if you play together this takes
place in 2049 if you played it out
you know 30 years this could very well
be what our reality is if that kind of
hate is allowed to
to fester i knew that the idea was that
we were taking
these big canvases and we're telling
very small stories
small stories i can tell i know how to
do the big canvases
i needed help you know and that was with
this incredible cinematographer
uh martin roo and with these great the
effects guys and they really helped us
and then you know it's easy when you go
out in
iceland on 70 mile an hour wind it's 40
degrees below zero
it doesn't take a whole lot of acting to
be cold
you know or be in pain you want to be an
explorer
but while you're doing all that your own
life is just
slipping away that's why i have to
contact them
ilm came in with these huge led
backdrops
that we used that had cameras facing our
camera
so that the backdrops for just for the
winter stuff outside
when we're in the snow so that when
the camera moved the the the camera
shooting the camera would know and would
change the backdrop to the angle of
where we were moving to really amazing
stuff and it was a technical nightmare
as you can imagine
but you know we finished ahead of
schedule and under budget we did
everything we were supposed to do
you know it's about the idea of first
and foremost what man could do to man
if we don't pay attention what we are
capable of doing
but it's also about the spirit of who we
really are
you know if you boil us down and that
there's this
need for redemption and this need
to be good and kind and fair
and all of those things that as as the
film comes to its climax there's all of
these judgments that are made the two
guys who decide to go home
there's a judgment made there i owe to
my wife or
i want to take this girl home you know
there are these things that are you know
life and death decisions but they're
they show such great
human character that i i i just love the
script because of that i love the idea
of the story
also you know we watched it a couple
days ago you know unfortunately for a
lot of people i don't get to see it on a
giant screen we shot on 65 so we watched
it a couple days ago in westwood at the
village
on this big screen and you know
it's just stunning the the the shots
that those that
that they put together the even the the
spaceship stuff
out in the space of spacewalk when you
see it you know in 65 it's really
something
so in gravity you worked with director
alfonso quaron did you take what you
learned with him
and apply it to this one the thing about
gravity alfonso was this
genius we were doing scenes in gravity
that they hadn't yet
invented the technology for i had like
the wildest experiences of like they'd
put a vr
you know headset on and then i'd hold
another
you know a camera in my hand and in the
vr i'd be walking on the spaceship that
doesn't exist it's all
in vr inside this empty gymnasium
and there'd be a big monitor behind
there with the dp watching it
and i would walk through all the
crevices on the outside of the for the
space walk
and i'd look up there and you could see
the antenna there i go okay this is the
angle this is the shot for here
they'd mark it down and i'd walk around
so i was able to actually
shoot as if i was on this giant thing
that we built when we were only going to
build
pieces of it and the rest was going to
be cgi
amazing experience and a great lesson my
goal in my career
was to always say look i and i just i
would say it constantly
uh and luckily my agents were kind about
that which i just said look
my job is you know i i don't want to
worry about
i don't want to just be able at the end
of my career to say how many films open
the number one
you know i don't care about the opening
weekend i wanted them to be
films that would hold up longer than an
opening weekend and
i've been lucky enough to have a few and
you know that
that makes me feel very i'm very i feel
very lucky